hello and welcome to my tutorial
concerning pythons reload and function
what I like about the reload function is
it opens up doors to a lot of things
that people didn't even know as possible
or actually thought was impossible so
one of my double majors at my university
was philosophy and sometimes a topic of
computers slash machine learning slash
like machines thinking kit would come up
and pretty much everybody would agree
that a computer could never become like
humans because programs require a human
to you know give it input and teach it
there in white code for it you know and
so whatever your actual belief is as far
as why you're here in your existence and
all that the the idea of boiled down to
the idea the supposed fact that code
could never write its own code right so
you know everybody whether or not you
believe in God or evolution or whatever
I mean everybody's you know you come out
with some stuff right you you know how
to breathe you have a brain that's kind
of built to learn and then it just like
a sponge starts absorbing things and so
why can't one create a program that does
the exact same thing and update itself
live well people say that well code
can't write code well this happens
really all the time with things like
installers and updates and all this kind
of stuff to programs this allows you to
make changes to your live system right
your computer but this can also be
demonstrated at a very basic level in a
single script with pythons reload
function so the idea of this is that
Python can indeed edit its own
programming code its own you know back
in driving code not just variables it
can edit the functions and everything so
this really means a lot of fun can
actually be achieved with this and we
can begin
embarking on some pretty neat ideas or
you could just use the reload function
to allow users to change defaults or
even some of the core functionality to
your applications and your programs
without that user ever having to close
out of the program if you want to be you
know I don't know boring like that or
you can actually you know start to make
it you know a human machine so with that
let's go ahead and get started with an
example of this reload function so for
now we're gonna reload our import reload
e.x and so i've created a function in my
site packages right like a module I've
created my own module called reload
example and Earth X and if I edit it
this is what it says it's just reload
exe I define skills empty parameters try
the same I'm Matt my skill is my skill
sets are what skillets are men and my
skill sets are math and if there's an
exception it prints it but this all it's
all it's doing is just saying something
right but it's you know this is just raw
coding so now if we let me save the new
one now and if I bring this over here
now and we'll just minimize this again
if you if you want to make the program
just like pause the video on this and
you can just write this out really quick
and to save it you would save it
wherever your Python directory is then
Lib with a capital L site packages and
just throw it in there you probably got
a bunch of site packages in there so
continuing on let me move this aside so
we're gonna reload or we're gonna load
that function I've still left it up so
just leave it up once you've made it now
we've got we're gonna make a main loop
so to find main and this is again this
isn't our tutorial file not the module
the module is all done now in here we're
gonna have a try and except as always
French drink and now we're gonna do
every time it's going to reload and it's
gonna reload what reload example and now
we're going to print actually let's not
print anything here and now we do reload
example dot skills so this reference is
the imported function that we just did
which references the skills function
here so when this when we call this it's
going to run this function and it's
gonna print my skill sets our math so
we'll do that that's all we really need
to do we'll just pass down here now the
next thing we're gonna do is wow true
run main and then we're just gonna have
like this thing that is raw input and
it's just gonna say enter to continue so
it's just kind of like something that's
gonna pause our script for us and go
when we press ENTER right it's just kind
of a hacky way to do a press ENTER to
continue function how do you with your
script so we'll just do that so save
that run that hopefully won't have any
errors and we don't so let me bring this
over now so it says my skill sets are
math press ENTER to continue press Enter
still math but if we bring over them the
module that we've imported we can make a
live edit to this like math and saw and
save it come over here
press Enter and now it says actually oh
my my skill sets are math and science
now some of you guys may not be you know
intrigued too much by this but it's
actually a huge huge thing to be able to
do because you can reload that function
and then what you can do later on down
the road is something like this open C
colon slash Python 27 Lib and then it's
like site packages and reload example
dot pi with the intention
to either write or append but probably
first you would read it and then read it
into memory make your changes and then
you would save it and so you can
actually have the program editing its
own core functions so pretty cool thing
to do whether or not you actually want
to make a robot or something that truly
does learn like a human or you want to
make live edits to your program it's a
good thing to know so anyways that's
going to conclude the what I would call
an introduction to the reload function
because there's a lot of stuff that you
can do with this that you might not be
realizing but that'll cover the basics
for now hopefully you guys found that
interesting I was really excited when I
found that ability so as always thanks
for watching thanks for the support in
the subscriptions and until next time